so that's such a great question okay so
if I were to think about I don't know if
that's cultural but it certainly existed
there's a there's a theme of respecting
Islam that has gone across which is sort
of a pride a pride thing that's not a
cultural thing but it's a it's a data
point across across every community that
I've been to every ethnicity every Creed
every culture that there is a a pride in
what it means to be Muslim and that that
that there is an importance of placing
being proud of putting faith out on the
table it's written really interesting
the gentleman right before you talked
about Europe one of the things i found
the job i had the reason why i know so
much by the way about your office
because of the job i had before this one
was to focus only on European Muslims
and I did that for two and a half years
so I know it really well you stepped
into the mud I'm sorry but you asked a
really good question one of the things
that I thought was really interesting
about my time in Europe was despite the
difficulty of a lot of these questions I
that I answered and the various
different cultures across Europe what
was really interesting is that there was
one country that got it what's it the
acceptability of saying that you're
religious what was the country what
country in Europe thinks it's okay to
have a faith and be proud of it when the
rest of Europe quote-unquote thinks god
is dead who's in Ireland gold star yep
you go to Ireland and there they're like
we get it we understand it's it's cool
it's fine you can be you can be Muslim
and be proud of that nowhere else in
Europe do you do you see that
conversation taking place so I'm saying
to you and I'm not just speaking about
Europe in many parts of the world
Muslims want to be able to say most
being as long Islamic is an important
thing for us we want to be proud of it
we want to talk about it I don't know if
you want to call that cultural but it's
definitely a data point that's gone
that's gone across for sure